i am here guys with nicole yokic and
nicola
you guys have proven time and time again
that you play your best basketball when
your backs are up against the wall
why i don't know i don't know that's a
good question i mean the effort wasn't
that was amazing and we were down 16 i
mean we were not 16 last game without 16
against utah one time we don't want to
be in that spot but it seems like
we are good at that spot uh i'm joking
uh we uh
i don't know the just the the switch
that we had in the third quarter
it was amazing the energy was there that
defense was there
we were making shots uh the whole team
the whole team played
played really well so i don't know it
was a amazing game for us
and nicola it is well documented that
gary harris has struggled since coming
to orlando a little bit jamal murray was
down on the floor in agony at one point
during this game
what did they do for your for your team
today
dramaal is he's a fighter he's a dog who
is never going to quit i know i knew
i knew that he's not going to get out of
the game he's uh he's an
amazing amazing uh the guy who is
there is there is no end for him like
the sky's the limit for real
and uh gary will step up and we need him
i mean gary
and and jg uh jeremy are playing a
really amazing job
in defense events so i mean
and you were pretty impressive yourself
both in passing and scoring you you were
doing a lot you were doing all right
where where do you draw from
as you were doing those things i mean i
i think it's a difference
when we get the stars and we have a
couple consider consecutive stops
in a row the the ball is the moving we
are flying
the the ball is going so probably just
for the energy that we have uh from a
defensive end just when we start running
in the offense
we're a really good team and finally
nicola this is the second straight
series that you have gone to seven games
what can you draw on that gives you
confidence from the utah series
this is the fourth series that we're
going for last year we were going to the
game seven two times
so i mean just have fun like we don't
have pressure
i think the old pressure is on them we
just go out there and have fun
effort i always say effort needs to be
on a high level have fun
and give your best thanks nicola all the
pressure